The following
content is provided
under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help MIT
OpenCourseWare continue
to offer high-quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
PROFESSOR: The last topic
we discussed on Monday it
was the situation of the
Landau-Zener transition
that you sweep for resonance.
You've all seen the
Landau-Zener formula,
you all know that in crossing
turns into an avoided crossing.
But I tried to at least
provide you additional insight
by emphasizing that the whole
process is absolute coherent.
That it's full-phase
coherent throughout.
And what happens is there is a
coherent transfer of amplitude
from the state 1 to the state 2.
This is nothing else than
Schrodinger's equation.
But I want to point out
that for the short times
you sweep through, there
is no T2 independence here.
In other words, when
I discussed what
is the effective
time during which
the transfer of
population takes place,
at the time here is so
short that the detuning
doesn't matter.
Actually, the
criterion which leads
to this effective time during
which the transfer takes place
is actually exactly
the time window
where the detuning
is small enough
that-- to say it
loosely, it doesn't
make a difference whether your
in resonance or slightly away.
The atom experiences
the same tri field.
And so based on
this criterion, we
discussed that we can understand
the Landau-Zener probability
in the perturbative limit
as a coherent process
where we transfer population,
we transfer amplitude
with a Rabi frequency during
this effective time, delta t.
It's not the only way
how we can look at it,
but it's one way which
I think is insightful.
Any questions about this or
what we discussed on Monday?
If not, I would like to take
the topic one step further
and discuss the density
matrix formalism.
So we have so far
discussed purely
Hamiltonian unitary evolution.
Namely, the
Schrodinger equation.
And of course, unitary
evolution leaves the system
which is in a pure
state in a pure state.
It's just that the
quantum state evolves.
However, that means we cannot
describe processes like
decoherence or some losses
away from the two levels we are
focusing on.
And so now we want to
use the density operator,
the density operator
formalism to have
a description of two-level
system which goes beyond that.
So let me just-- so Schrodinger
equation deals only with pure
states, cannot describe loss
of particles, loss of photons,
and decoherence.
Well, there is one exception.
If the decoherence process is
merely a state-dependent loss
of atoms to a third
state, then you
can still use the wave
function formalism.
So this is the exception.
If you have two states,
that's the excited state.
If you have two states
and all of what happens
is that you have some
loss to some other levels
and their rate
coefficients, then one
can still use a
Hamiltonain description,
but you have to replace the
eigenvalues by complex numbers.
In other words, you have to add
an imaginary part to the energy
levels.
And that means
the time evolution
is exponentially dent.
So that's as much as you
can incorporate decoherence
and losses into a wave
function formalism.
However, many other processes
require the formalism
of the density matrix.
And the simplest process
where wave function formalism
is absolutely inadequate
is the process
of spontaneous emission.
When you have a loss
in the excited state,
you could still describe
the excited state
with a complex
energy eigenvalue.
But the fact that whatever is
lost from the excited state
is added to the ground state.
There is no wave
function formalism
which can describe that.
So for those processes and
for decoherence in general,
we require the use of
the density operator.
So I know that most
of you have seen
the density operator in
statistical mechanics
or some advanced course
in quantum mechanics.
So therefore, I only spend
about five minutes on it.
So I want to kind of just
remind you or give you
a very short introduction.
So for those of you who
have never heard about it,
I probably say enough
that you understand
the following discussion.
And for those of you who know
already everything about it,
five minutes of recapitulation
is hopefully not too boring.
So my way of introducing
the density operator
is first introduce it formally.
Write down a few
equations for pure state.
But then in a moment,
add something to it.
So if you have a time-dependent
wave function, which
we expand into eigenfunctions,
then we can, in these spaces,
define arbitrary
operators by matrices.
We want to describe our
system by finding out
measurable observables,
expectation
values of operators, which
of course, depend on time.
And this is, of course, nothing
else than the expectation value
taken with a time-dependent
wave function.
But now we can expand
it into the bases m, n
and we can then rewrite
it as a matrix, which
is a density matrix.
Or, simply as the
trace of the density
matrix with the operator.
And what I introduced here
as the density matrix can
be written as psi
of t, psi of t.
And the matrix element
given by this combination
of amplitudes when we
expand the wave function
psi into its basis.
So this density matrix his
diagonal and off-diagonal
matrix elements.
The diagram matrix elements
are called the populations,
the populations in state n
and the off-diagonal matrix
elements are called coherences.
OK, so this is just rewriting
Schrodinger's equation
expectation value in
a matrix formalism.
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: Why are you
starring the coefficients?
PROFESSOR: Oh, there's
one star too many.
Thank you.
AUDIENCE: That makes sense.
PROFESSOR: But the
reason why I wrote it
is that we want to now add
some probability to it.
We do not know for sure that
the system is in a pure state.
We have probabilities
P i that the system
is in a quantum state psi i.
So we add another index to it.
And when we perform
the expectation value--
there's also one star too many.
When we perform the
expectation value,
we sort of do it for
each quantum state
with a probability P i.
So we are actually-- and this
is what I wanted to point out.
This was the purpose of
this short discussion,
that we are now actually
performing two averages.
One can be regarded
as the normal quantum
mechanical average when
you find the average value
or the expectation
value for quantum state.
So this is sort of the
statistics or the averaging,
which is inherent
in quantum physics.
But then in addition,
there may simply
be another probabilistic
average because you have not
prepared the system
in a pure state,
or the system may undergo
some stochastic forces
and wind up in different states.
So there are two kinds of
averages which are performed.
And the advantage of the
density matrix formalism
is that both kinds of averages
can be done simultaneously
in a very compact formalism.
So therefore, I put this
probabilistic average in now
into the definition
of the density matrix.
Or I can write the density
matrix in this way.
And with this extended
definition of the density
matrix, both kinds
of averages are
done when I determine the
expectation value and operator
by performing the trace
with the density matrix.
A lot of properties
of the density matrix,
I think are-- you're
familiar with many of those.
For instance, that Schrodinger's
equation for the density matrix
becomes this following equation.
You can derive that by-- if you
take the Schrodinger equation
and you apply the Schrodinger
equation to each state psi i.
And then you do the averaging
with a probability P i.
You find that the Schrodinger
equation for each state
psi i turns into this equation
for the density matrix.
Let me just write down
that the purpose now
is we have two averages here.
One is the quantum
mechanic average and one
is sort of an ensemble average
with the probabilities P i.
I want to discuss
in a few moments
the density matrix
for two-level system.
So I have to remind
you of two properties,
that the density matrix
is normalized to unity.
So there's probability of
unity to find the system
in one of the states.
When we look at the
square of the density
matrix, a trace of
rho square, this
is simply the probability-- the
sum of the probability squared.
And this is smaller than 1.
And the only way that it
is one is for pure state.
So pure state is
characterized by the fact
that there is only-- that
we can find the basis where
only one of the probabilities,
P i is non-vanishing.
And then, of course, almost
trivially the trace rho is 1
and the trace rho square is 1.
So, so far I've presented
you the density matrix
just as an elegant way
of integrating the two
averages into one formalism.
And in essence,
this is what it is.
But you can now also
use the density matrix
if the whole system undergoes
a time evolution, which
is no longer unitary.
No longer described by
a Hamilton operator.
Because you're
interested in the time
evolution or a
small system which
is part of a bigger system.
The bigger system is always
described by unitary time
evolution, but a smaller
system is usually not described
by unitary time evolution.
And that's when the density
matrix becomes crucial.
Of course, you can see this is
just you describe the smaller
system and you do some
probabilistic average what
the other part of
the system does.
And therefore, it's just another
version of doing two averages.
But this is sort of why
we want to use the density
matrix in general.
So we want to use the density
matrix for non-unitary time
evolution.
And the keyword here
is that this is often
the situation for
open systems where
we are interested
in a small system,
but it is open to
a bigger system.
Like, we're interested
to describe an atom,
but the atom can
spontaneously emit photons
into other parts of
[INAUDIBLE] space.
And we're not interested
in those other parts
of [INAUDIBLE] space.
So an open system
for this purpose
is where we limit
our description
to a small part of
a larger system.
Again, an atom interacting
with all the modes
of the electromagnetic
field, but we simply
want to describe the atom.
And then, we cannot use
a wave function anymore.
We have to use the
density matrix.
OK
After these
preliminaries, I want
to now use the density
matrix formalism
for arbitrary two-level systems.
So what is the most
general Hamiltonian
for the most general
two-level system?
Well, the most
general Hamiltonian
is the most general
Hamiltonian we
can construct with
2 by 2 matrices.
And the base is
set to expand the 2
by 2 matrices are
the Pauli matrices.
So if you expand the Hamiltonian
into the unity matrix, sigma x,
sigma y, and sigma z, we
have four coefficients,
four amplitudes, which are
complex in general-- omega
1, omega 2, omega 3.
And here is something which
I've called omega bar.
By appropriately shifting
what is the 0 point of energy,
we can always get rid of this.
So this is just this
definitional character.
So therefore, the most
general Hamiltonian
for any two-level system
can be written in this very
compact way that it is the
scalar product of the vector
omega-- omega 1, omega 2,
omega 3-- with the vector
sigma of the three Pauli
matrices-- sigma x, sigma y,
sigma z.
OK, so this is a
way to write down
the most general Hamiltonian
for a two-level system.
Now, we describe two-level
systems by a density matrix,
by statistical operator,
which is also a 2 by 2 matrix.
And the most general
density matrix
can also be expanded into
the its four components.
Sort of the basis
set of matrices
is the unitary matrix and
the three Pauli matrices.
So 1, 2, 3.
Of course, this time we cannot
throw away the unity matrix
because otherwise the density
matrix would have no trace
and there would be no
probability to find
the particle.
But we can, again, write
it in a compact form
that it is 1/2-- yes,
I'm using the fact now
that the trace of rho is r0.
And this is, by definition, or
by conservation of probability,
is 1.
So therefore, r0 is
not a free parameter.
It's just the sum of
all the probabilities
to find the system in any state.
And the non-trivial part
is then the scalar product
of this vector r-- rx, ry, rz--
with the vector of the three
Pauli matrices.
Well, so we have our
most general Hamiltonian.
We have our most
general density matrix.
And now we can insert
this into the equation
of motion for the
density matrix.
Which, as I said before,
is just a reformulation
of Schrodinger's equation.
And if you insert the
Hamiltonian and the density
matrix into this
equation, we find actually
something which is very simple.
It says that this
vector r, which
we call the Bloch vector-- the
derivative of the Bloch vector
is given by the cross product
of the vector omega, which
were the coefficients with which
we parametrized the Hamiltonian
cross r.
The derivation is
straightforward.
And you will be asked to do
that on your homework assignment
number 1.
But it has a very
powerful meaning.
It tells us that an
arbitrary two-level system
with an arbitrary
Hamiltonian can
be regarded as a system
where we have a vector
R which undergoes precession.
This is the time
evolution of the system.
So this is a powerful
generalization
from the result we
discussed previously
where we found that if
you have an arbitrary
quantum-mechanical spin,
the time derivative can
be written in that way.
So previously, we found
it for a pure state,
but now we find
it-- that it's even
valid for a general density
matrix and its time evolution.
So what I've derived for
you is-- Classroom Files.
Is a famous theorem,
which is traced back
to Feynman, Vernon,
and Hellwarth.
It's sort of a
famous paper which--
So this famous
theorem-- and I've
summarized it here
for you-- says
that the time evolution of the
density matrix for the most
general two-level system is
isomorphic to pure precession.
And that means it's
isomorphic to the behavior
of a classical moment,
classical magnetic moment,
in a suitable time-dependent
magnetic field.
So when you have a
Hamiltonian, which
is characterized by-- the
most general Hamiltonian
is characterized by the three
coefficients-- w1, w2, w3.
But if you would create
a classical system
where w1, w2, and w3 are the
time-dependent components,
xyz-component of a
magnetic field, then
the precession of
a magnetic moment
would be exactly the same
as the time evolution
of a quantum-mechanical
density matrix.
Any question?
So in other words,
we've started out
with rotating
frames and rotation
and now we've gone
as far as I will go.
Namely, I've in a
way told you that
an arbitrary quantum-mechanical
two-level system, the time
evolution is just precession.
It's rotation.
There is nothing more
complicated possible.
Well, unless we talk
about decoherence.
If we have such a Hamiltonian,
we know, of course,
that a pure state will
stay pure forever.
And you can immediately
verify that if you
look at the trace of rho square.
If the trace of rho square
is 1, we have a pure state.
And now we have parametrized
the density matrix
with the Bloch vector
component-- r1, r2, r3.
So in those components,
the trace of rho square
can be written in this way.
And of course, r0
square was constant.
This was our normalization of 1.
So the question is now when
we have an arbitrary time
evolution, which we
know now according
to the Feynman, Vernon,
Hellwarth theorem.
The arbitrary time evolution
of the Bloch vector
can be written as omega cross r.
So this equation
tells us immediately
that the length of the
vector r is constant
because r dot is
always orthogonal to r.
And therefore, the lengths of
the vector r is not changing.
So what we have derived says
that with the most general
Hamiltonian, the lengths of
the vector r will be constant.
And therefore, the trace of
rho square will be constant.
This is constant because r
dot is perpendicular to r.
So this will tell us that
a pure state will just
precess with the constant
lengths of its Bloch vector
forever.
However, we know that in real
life some coherences are lost
and now we have to
introduce something else.
So this does not describe
loss of coherence.
So now we are just
one tiny step away
from introducing
the Bloch equations.
We will fully feature the
optical Bloch equations
in 8.422.
but since we have discussed
two-level systems to quite some
extent, I cannot resist
to show you now in three,
four minutes what the
Bloch equations are.
And then when you take the
second part of the course,
you will already be
familiar with it.
So let me just now
tell you what has
to be added to do this step
from the previous formalism
to the Bloch equations.
And this is the one
step you have to do.
We have to include relaxation
processes into the description.
So my less than five-minute
way to now derive the Bloch
equations for you
goes as follows.
I first remind you
that everything
has to come to
thermal equilibrium.
In other words, if you
have an atomic system,
if you have a quantum
computer, whatever system you
have and you prepared
in a pure state,
you know if you
will wait forever,
the system will be described
by a density matrix, which
is the density matrix of
thermal equilibrium, which
has only diagonal
matrix elements.
The populations follow
the [INAUDIBLE] factor.
And everything is normalized
by the partition function.
So we know that this will
happen after long, long times.
So no matter with what
density matrix we start out,
if we start with a
density matrix rho
pure state, for instance,
there will be inevitably
some relaxation process which
will restore rho to rho t,
to the thermal equilibrium.
Now, how this happens
can be formulated
in a microscopic way.
And we will go through
a beautiful derivation
of a master equation
and really provide
some insight what
causes relaxation.
But here for the
purpose of this course,
I want to say, well,
there is relaxation.
And I want to introduce now,
in a phenomenological way,
damping and damping times.
So the phenomenological
way to introduce damping
goes as follows.
Our equation of motion
for the density matrix
was that this is a unitary
evolution described
by-- the Schrodinger
equation was that the density
matrix evolves according
to the commutative
with the Hamiltonian.
But now-- and I have to pick
big quotation marks around it
because this is not a
mathematically exact way
of writing it.
But now I want to
introduce some term which
will damp the density matrix to
the thermal equilibrium density
matrix with some
equilibration time, Te.
I mean, this is
what you can always
do if you know the
system is damped.
You have some
coherent evolution,
but eventually you
added a damping term
and you make the damping term--
you formulate in such a way
that asymptotically
the system will
be damped to the
thermal equilibrium.
In other words, the
damping term will
have no effect on the
dynamics once you've
reached equilibrium.
So it does all the right things.
Of course, we have to
be a little bit careful
because everything is either
an operator or matrix.
And I was just adding
the damping term
as you would probably do it
to a one-dimensional equation.
So therefore, let me be a
little bit more specific.
In many cases, you
will find that there
are two distinctly
different relaxation times.
In other words, the system
will have usually at least two
physically distinct
relaxation times.
They are traditionally
called T1 and T2.
T1 is the damping time for
population differences.
So this is the damping
time to shovel population
from some inverted state
or some other state
into the equilibrium state.
That usually
involves the removal
of energy out of the system.
So it's an energy decay time.
And if you would inspect our
parameterization of the Bloch
vector, population or
population differences
are described by
the z-component,
the third component
of the Bloch vector.
Well, we have other
components of the Bloch vector
which correspond to coherences.
The off-diagonal matrix
element of the density matrix.
And they're only nonzero if
you have two states populated
with a value-defined
relative phase.
When the system, quantum
mechanical system,
loses its memory of the
phase, the r1 and r2 component
of the Bloch vector go to 0.
So therefore, the
time T2 is a time
which describes the loss of
coherences, the dephasing
times.
And in most situations,
well, if you lose energy,
you've also lost--
if you lose energy
because you quench
a quantum state,
you've also lost the phase.
So therefore in general,
T2 is smaller than T1.
Often by a lot.
So with those remarks about
the two damping times,
I can now go back to the
equation at the top, which
was sort of written
with quotation marks,
and write it in a more accurate
way as a matrix equation
for the damping of the
components of the density
matrix expressed by
the Bloch vector.
In other words, the
equation of motion
for the z-component
of the Bloch vector,
which is describing
the population,
has a coherent part, which is
this generalized precession.
And then, it has a damping part,
which damps the populations
to the equilibrium value
with a damping time T1.
And then we have the
corresponding equations
for the x and y, or the 1 or 2
component of the optical Bloch
vector.
We just replace the z index by
x and y from the equation above,
but then we divide by a
different relaxation time, T2.
So what we have
found here, these
are the famous Bloch
equations, which
were introduced
by Bloch in 1946.
Introduced first for
magnetic resonance,
but they're also valid
in the optical domain.
For magnetic resonance, you
have a two-level system,
spin up and spin down.
In the optical domain, you have
a ground and excited state.
In the latter
case, they're often
referred to as the
optical Bloch equations.
Any questions about that?
Yes, please.
AUDIENCE: So what
determines [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: Well, that's
a long discussion.
We spent a long time in 8.422
discussing various processes.
But just to give you an example,
if you have a gas of atoms
and there are slightly
inhomogeneous magnetic field,
that would mean that each atom,
if you look at it as precession
motion, precesses at
slightly differently rates.
And the atoms will decohere.
They all will eventually wind
up with a different phase,
that if you look at the average
of coherence, it's equal to 0.
So any form of
inhomogeneity, which
is not quenching a quantum
state, which is not
creating any form of
de-activation of the excited
state, can actually
decohere the phase.
And these are
contributions to T2.
So often, contributions
to T2 come
from inhomogeneous
environment, but they are not
changing the
population of states.
Whereas, what contributes
to T1 are often collisions.
Collisions which, when an
atom in an excited state
collides with the
buffer gas atom,
it undergoes a transition
from the excited to the ground
state.
So these are two distinctly
different processes.
One is really a collision
and energy transfer.
Each atom has to change
its quantum state.
Whereas, decoherence
can simply happen
that there is a small
pertubation of the energy
levels due to external fields.
And then, the system as an
ensemble loses its phase.
In the simplest
way, you can assume
inhomogeneous broadening.
But you can also assume,
if the whole ensemble
is subject to
fluctuating fields,
then since you don't know
how the fields exactly
fluctuate after characteristic
time, you no longer have
a phased coherent system.
Rather, phase at a later time
is deterministically related
to the phase at which
you prepared it.
And that would mean the
system has dephased.
And this dephasing time
is called the T2 time.
Nancy.
AUDIENCE: I think
I have two things.
First, you said that
it's generally true
that T2 is less than T1.
Is it ever true that
it's not the case?
PROFESSOR: Oh.
There is one exception.
And that's the following.
Let me put it this way, every
process which contributes to T1
will also contribute to T2.
But there are lots of processes
which only contribute to T2.
So therefore, in general,
T2 is much faster
because many more processes
can contribute to it.
However, now if you ask
me, is it always true?
Well, there is one glitch.
And this is the following.
T1 is the time to
damp populations.
And that's the
damping of psi square.
T2 is due to the
damping of the phase.
And this is actually more
a damping time of the wave
function itself.
And if you have a wave
function psi which
is damped with a
damping time tau.
Psi square is damped with
twice the damping time.
So if the only process
you have is, for instance,
spontaneous emission,
then you find out
that the damping rate
for population is gamma.
This is the definition of the
spontaneous emission rate.
But the damping rate 1
over T2 is 1/2 gamma.
But because simply the way
how we have defined it,
one involves the square
of the wave function.
The other one involves
simply the wave function.
So there is this
factor of 2 which
can make-- by just a factor
of 2-- T1 faster than T2.
But apart from this
factor of 2, if T2
would be defined in a way
which would incorporate
the factor of 2, then T2 would
always be faster than T1.
AUDIENCE: Yeah, it
makes sense [INAUDIBLE].
I can't imagine if the
system has a smaller T1,
then it still has any
coherence left in it.
PROFESSOR: So maybe to
be absolutely correct,
I should say this.
T1 is much larger than-- is
larger or equal than T2 over 2.
In general, we have
even the situation
that T1 is much,
much larger than T2.
But with this factor
of 2, I've incorporated
this subtlety of the definition.
Other questions?
Yes.
AUDIENCE: Just a question
about real motivation
of using Bloch
equation [INAUDIBLE].
I understand that [INAUDIBLE].
But you mentioned
before that you
can't describe spontaneous
emission with a Hamiltonian
formalism.
PROFESSOR: Yes.
AUDIENCE: But couldn't
you use-- [INAUDIBLE].
Don't you still get spontaneous
emission out of the coupling
into the continuum?
The emission into
the different modes?
You don't necessarily
need [INAUDIBLE].
PROFESSOR: Yes, but let me
kind of remind you of this.
If you are interested in
a quantum state and it
decays to a level.
But we're not really
interested what this level is
and we're not keeping
track of the population
here, when we can describe the
time evolution of the excited
state with a Hamiltonian
because of the imaginary part,
the Hamiltonian is
no longer imaginary.
And this is what Victor
Weisskopf theory does.
It looks at a system
in the excited state
and looks at the time
evolution of the excited state.
But if you want to include
in this description what
happens in the ground state, you
are not having this situation.
You have this situation.
And what eventually
will happen is
you can look at a pure
state which decays.
And this is what is done
in Victor Weisskopf theory.
But if you want to know now what
happens in the ground state,
well, I'm speaking loosely,
but that's what really happens.
Every spontaneous emission adds
something to the ground state,
but in incoherent way.
So what is being built
up in the ground state
is not a wave function.
It's just population which has
to be described with a density
matrix.
Or in other words, if you have
a coherent superposition between
excited and ground state, you
cannot just say spontaneous
emission is now increasing the
amplitude to be in the ground
state.
It really does something
fundamentally different.
It puts population into the
ground state with-- I'm loosely
speaking now, but
with a random phase.
And this can only be
described probabilistically
by using the density matrix.
But what you are talking
about is actually,
for the Victor Weisskopf
theory, is pretty much
this part of the diagram.
We prepare an excited
state, and we study it
with all its glorious
details, with the many modes
of the electromagnetic field
how the excited state decays.
OK.
Actually with that, we have
finished one big chapter
of our course, which is
the general discussion
of resonance, classical
resonance, and our discussion
of two-level systems.
AUDIENCE: But
[INAUDIBLE], wouldn't you
have to do a sum over every
single mode [INAUDIBLE]?
Which would be the
exact same thing
you do when you do a partial
trace over the environment.
Isn't the end result
sort of the same thing
that you have to do some
[INAUDIBLE] infinite
sum and integral or
all the [INAUDIBLE]?
PROFESSOR: You need a sum, but--
AUDIENCE: That's where the
decoherence comes from?
PROFESSOR: Yes.
But if you're interested in only
the decay of an excited state,
it can decay in
many, many modes,
but all these different
modes provide a contribution
to the decay rate gamma.
So at the end of the day, you
have a Hamiltonian evolution
with a damping time gamma.
And this damping time gamma is
the sum of the other states.
So in other words, the loss
of population from the excited
state, you just incorporate
it by adding a damping time
to the Schrodinger
equation because you're not
keeping track of the other
modes where the population goes.
You're not keeping track.
You just say, excited
state is lost.
You're not interested
whether the atoms are now
in the ground state
or some other state.
All you are describing the loss
rate from the excited state.
And this is possible
by simply doing--
by adding damping terms to
the Schrodinger equation.
In other words, what I'm saying
is actually fairly simple.
If you have a coherent
state and you lose it,
you just lose amplitude.
what is left is coherent.
When it's gone, it's gone.
You have a smaller amplitude,
smaller probability.
And that's simple to describe.
What is harder to describe
is if you accumulate
population in the ground
state and the population
arrives in incoherent pieces.
How to treat that, this
is more complicated.
But simply the decay
of a pure state,
it's just-- you have e
to the i omega t, which
is a coherent evolution, and
then you add an imaginary part
and this is a damping time.
So what I'm saying,
it's sort of subtle
but it's also very trivial.
I don't know if this
addresses your question.
In the end, in general
you need a density matrix.
I just wanted to
sort of emphasize
that there is a little bit of
decoherence where you can still
get away with a wave
function description.
And actually, Victor
Weisskopf theory
is the wonderful example.
OK, so we have
discussed resonance.
Arizonans have discussed in
particular two-level systems.
And if I wanted, we could now
continue with two-level systems
and talk about the
wonderful things
you can do with
two-level systems.
Absorbing photons, emitting
photons, and all that.
But let's put that on
hold for a few weeks.
And I think what
we should first do
is realize, where do
those levels come from?
And we discuss where
those levels come form
in our discussion of atoms.
So our big next chapter is
now atoms or atomic structure.
And we build it up
in several stages.
Well, first things first.
And the first things are
the big chunks of energy
which define the
electronic structure.
We discuss electronic structure
for one electron and two
electron atoms,
hydrogen and helium.
We don't go higher in
the periodic table.
But then we talk about
other contributions
to the energy of atoms, other
contributions to the level
structure of atoms.
And this will start with fine
structure, the Lamb shift.
We bring in properties
of the nucleus
by discussing
hyperfine structure.
And then as a next
big chapter, we
will learn how external
fields, magnetic fields,
electric fields, and
electromagnetic fields
will modify the level
structure of atoms.
So by going through all
those different layers,
we will arrive at a rather
complete description.
If you have an atom
in the laboratory,
what determines its energy
level and the transitions
between those energy levels?
So this is our agenda for
the next few lectures.
Today, we start with single
electron atom with a hydrogen
atom.
And I cannot resist to start
with some quotes from Dan
Kleppner, who I sometimes
call Mr. Hydrogen.
So there is some beautiful
piece of writing in a reference
frame in Physics Today, "The
Yin and Yang of Hydrogen."
I mean, those of you who
know Dan Kleppner know
that he's always said hydrogen
is the only atom, other atom he
wants to work with.
Other atoms are too complicated.
And he studied--
actually, hydrogen
was-- he did a little bit
on alkali atoms, of course,
but hydrogen was
really the central part
of his scientific work.
Whether he studied
Rydberg states
in hydrogen or Bose-Einstein
condensation in hydrogen.
And this column in
Physics Today, he
talks about the yin and yang.
The simplicity of hydrogen.
It's the simplest atom.
But if you want to
work with hydrogen,
you need vacuum UV
because the step
from the 1s to the 2p
transition is-- Lyman-alpha
is vacuum UV at 121 nanometer.
So it's simple, but challenging.
And hydrogen is the
most pristine atom.
But for those of you who do
Bose-Einstein condensation,
it's the hardest atom
to Bose condense.
Because the physical
properties of hydrogen,
it's simple in its structure.
But the properties
of hydrogen, in
particular the
collision cross-section,
which is important for
evaporative cooling,
is very, very unfavorable.
So that's why he talks about the
yin and the yang of hydrogen.
Let me just show you the
first sentence of this paper,
of this reference frame.
Oops.
Just a technical problem to
make this fit the screen.
I think I select it.
What's going on?
Yep.
So now it's smaller.
I can move it over there.
Well, why don't we
read it together?
It's a tribute to hydrogen,
a tribute to famous people.
Viki Weisskopf was on
the faculty at MIT.
I met him, but he was already
retired at this point.
But then, Kleppner
interacted with him.
And you see the first quote,
"To understand hydrogen
is to understand
all of physics."
Well, it simply says
that if you understand
some of this paradigmatic
systems in physics,
you understand all of physics.
I would actually
say, well, you really
have to understand the
harmonic oscillator,
the two-level
system, and hydrogen.
And maybe a little bit
about three-level systems.
But if you understand,
really, those simple systems--
they're not so simple.
But if you understand those
so-called simple system
very well in all
its glorious detail,
then you have really
understood, maybe
not all of physics, but a
hell of a lot of physics.
And this quote goes on that,
"To understand hydrogen
is to understand
all of physics."
But then Viki Weisskopf
said, "Well, I
wish I had understood
all of hydrogen."
And this is sort of Dan's
Kleppner's wise words.
For me, hydrogen holds an
almost mystical attraction.
Probably because I'm among
the small band of physicists
who actually confront
it, more or less, daily.
So that's what we are starting
out now to talk about hydrogen.
I know that a discussion of
the hydrogen atom, the solution
of the Schrodinger equation
for the hydrogen atom
is in all quantum
mechanics textbooks.
I'm not doing it here.
I rather want to give you
a few insightful comments
about the structure of hydrogen,
some scaling of length scales
and energy levels,
because this is
something we need
later in the course.
So in other words, I want to
highlight a few things which
are often not emphasized
in the textbook.
So let's talk about
the hydrogen atom.
So the energy levels
of the hydrogen atom
are described by
the Rydberg formula.
This actually follows already
from the simple Bohr model.
But of course, also from
the Schrodinger equation.
And it says that
the energy levels--
let me write it in
the following way.
It depends on the electron
mass, the electron charge, h bar
square.
It has a reduced
mass correction.
And then, n is the
principal quantum number.
It scales as 1 over n squared.
So this here is the
reduced mass factor.
This here is called the
Rydberg constant R, sometimes
with the index infinity
because it is the Rydberg
constant which describes the
spectrum of a hydrogen atom
where the nucleus
has infinite mass.
If you include the
reduced mass correction
for the mass of the
proton, then this factor
which determines the
spectrum of hydrogen
is called the Rydberg constant
with an index H for hydrogen.
You find the electronic
eigenfunctions
as the solution of
Schrodinger's equation.
And the eigenfunctions
have a simple angular part,
which are the
spherical harmonics.
We are not talking about that.
But there is a radial
part, radial wave function.
So if you solve it, if you
find those wave functions,
there are a number of
noteworthy results.
One is in short form the
spectrum is the Rydberg
constant divided by n squared.
I want to talk to you
about your intuition
for the size of
the hydrogen atom,
or for the size of
hydrogen-like atoms.
So what I want to discuss
is several important aspects
about the radius or
the expectation value
of the position of the electron.
And it's important
to distinguish
between the expectation
value for the radius
and the inverse radius.
The expectation
value for the radius
is, well, a little
bit more complicated.
1/2 1 minus l times l
plus 1 over n squared.
Whereas, the result for the
inverse radius is very simple.
What I've introduced here
is the natural length scale
for the hydrogen atom
which is the Bohr radius.
And just to be general,
mu is the reduced mass.
So it's close to
the electron mass.
Well, the one thing I
want to discuss with you--
we will need leader for the
discussion of quantum defects,
for field ionization
and other processes,
we have to know what the
size of the wave function is.
And so usually, if
you wave your hands,
you would say the
expectation value of 1/r
is 1 over the
expectation value or r.
But there are now some
important differences.
I first want to
sort of ask you, why
is the expectation
value of 1/r, why
does it have this
very, very simple form?
AUDIENCE: Virial theorem?
PROFESSOR: The Virial theorem.
Yes.
We know that there is a fairly
simple form for the energy
eigenvalues.
It's 1 over n squared.
Well, Coulomb energy
e square over r.
So if the only energy
of the hydrogen atom
were Coulomb energy,
it's very clear
that 1/r, which is proportional
to the Coulomb energy,
has to have the same simple
form as the energy eigenvalue.
Well, there is a
second contribution
to the energy in addition
to Coulomb energy.
This is kinetic energy.
But due to the Virial
theorem, the kinetic energy
is actually proportional
to the Coulomb energy.
And therefore, the total
energy is proportional to 1/r.
And therefore, 1/r has to
scale exactly as the energy.
Since the energy until we
introduce fine structure is
independent of l, only depends
on the principal quantum number
n, we find there's
only an n-dependence.
But if you would ask, what
is the expectation value
for the radius?
You find an l-dependence
because you're
talking about a very
different quantity.
So let me just summarize
what we just discussed.
We have the Virial
theorem, which
in general is of
the following form.
If you have potential
energy which
is proportional to
radius to the n,
then the expectation value
for the kinetic energy
is n/2 times the expectation
value for the potential energy.
The most famous
example is n equals
2, the harmonic oscillator.
You have an equal contribution
to potential energy
of the spring and
kinetic energy.
Well, here for the
Coulomb problem,
we discuss n equals minus 1.
And therefore,
the kinetic energy
is minus 1/2 times
the potential energy.
So this factor of 2 appears
now in a number of relations
and that's as follows.
If you take the
Rydberg constant,
the Rydberg constant
in CGS units
is-- well, that's the Coulomb
energy at the Bohr radius.
But the Rydberg
constant is 1/2 of it.
So the Rydberg constant is
1/2 of another quantity,
which is called 1 Hartree.
We'll talk, probably
not , today,
but on Monday
about atomic units,
about sort of fundamental
system of units.
And the fundamental way--
the fundamental energy
of the hydrogen atom, the
fundamental unit of energy
is whatever energy
you can construct
using the electron mass, the
electron charge, and h bar.
And what you get is 1 Hartree.
If you ever wondered why the
Rydberg is 1/2 Hartree, what
happens is in the ground
state of hydrogen,
you have 1 Hartree
worth of Coulomb energy.
But then because of the Virial
theorem, you have minus 1/2
of it as kinetic energy.
And therefore, the
binding energy in the n
equals 1 ground state,
which is 1 Rydberg,
is 1/2 of the Hartree.
So this factor of 1/2
of the Virial theorem
is responsible for this factor
of 2 for those two energies.
I usually prefer SI units
for all calculations,
but there's certain relations
where we should use CGS units.
Just as a side remark, if
you want to go to SI units,
you simply replace
the electron charge e
squared by e squared
divided by 4 pi epsilon0.
OK.
So I've discussed
the hydrogen atom.
It's also insightful
and you should actually
remember that or be able to
re-derive it for yourself.
How do things depend on
the nuclear charge z?
Well, if you have
a nuclear charge z,
the Coulomb energy
goes up by-- well,
if you have a
stronger attraction.
If you would go to helium
nucleus or even more
highly-charged nucleus and
put one electron in it.
Because of the stronger
Coulomb attraction,
all the length scales
are divided by z.
So everything is smaller
by a factor of z.
So what does that now
imply for the energy?
Well, you have a Coulomb field
which is z times stronger,
but you probe it now at
a z times smaller radius.
So therefore, the energies
scale with z squared.
Let me formulate a question
because we need that later on.
So if you have a
hydrogen-like atom
and the electron is in a state
with principal quantum number
n.
And let's assume there
is no angular momentum.
So what I'm writing down
for you is the probability
for the electron to
be at the nucleus.
This will be very
important later on
when ewe discuss hyperfine
structure because hyperfine
is responsible-- for
hyperfine structure, what
is responsible is the fact
that the electron can overlap
with the nucleus.
So this factor will
appear in our discussion
of hyperfine structure.
And what I want to ask you is,
how does this quantity depend
on the principal quantum
number n and on z?
And I want to give
you four choices.
Of course, for
dimensional reasons,
everything is 1
over the Bohr radius
cubed because it's a density.
But you cannot use
dimensional analysis to guess,
how do things scale
with z and with n?
So here are your four choices.
Does it scale with z,
z squared, z cubed?
Does it scale with n
squared, n cubed, n to the 6?
If you don't know it,
just make your best guess.
OK, one part should be
relatively straightforward.
And this is the scaling with z.
Let me just stop it.
So the exact answer is that z n
00 at the origin squared is pi
a0 cubed.
And its c cubed over n cubed.
So the correct
answer is this one.
Let me first say-- OK,
I gave you four choices
and it's difficult to
distinguish all of them.
But the first one you should
have gotten rather simply,
and this is the z-scaling.
Because the scaling
with z is the following,
that everything-- if you write
down the Schrodinger equation,
if you have z, you replace
e squared by z e squared.
And I actually just mentioned
it five minutes ago,
that all length scales, the
Bohr radius is h bar squared
over electron mass
times e squared.
It actually scales with 1/z.
So if all length
scales go as 1/z,
the density goes with z cubed.
So therefore, one should
have immediately narrowed
down the choice.
It should be A or
C because they have
the correct scaling with z.
The scaling with
n is more subtle
and there was something
surprising I learned about it.
And this is what
I want to present
to you in the last
three or four minutes.
So the z-scaling, just remember
that the length scaling
is the length scales as 1/z.
Therefore, density
scale was z cubed.
The interesting thing
about the length scaling
is-- and I just want to draw
your attention to it because it
can be confusing,
that in high torsion
we have not only one length
scale, but two length scales.
We have mentioned
one of it already,
which is the energetic
length scale 1/r.
1/r is the Coulomb energy.
Because of the
Virial theorem, it's
proportional to
the total energy.
And that's what you know, what
you remember when you wake up
in the middle of the
night out of deep sleep,
that the energy of high
torsion is 1 over n squared.
So therefore, this
is a0 over n squared.
However, if you look at the
wave function of hydrogen,
you factor out.
When you solve the
radial equation,
you factor out an exponential.
There's sort of
polynomial and then
there is an exponential decay.
And the characteristic lengths
in the exponential decay
of the wave function
is n e0 over z.
So therefore, when we
talk about wave functions
with principal quantum number
n, there are two length scale.
1 over r n l scales
with n squared.
But the characteristic
length scale
in the exponential
part of the radial wave
function scales with n
and not with n squared.
And it is this exponential
part of the wave function
which scales with n which is
responsible for the probability
to find the electron
as the nucleus.
Which, as I said before,
the z-scaling is simple
but the n-scaling
is not n to the 6.
It's n cubed.
And this is really important.
And this describes the
scaling with n for everything
which depends on the presence
of the electron as a nucleus.
One is the quantum
defect and the other one
is the hyperfine structure.
Let me just give you
one more scaling.
I've discussed now what
happens for 0 angular
momentum, for finite
angular momentum states,
psi is proportional
to r to the l.
So therefore, if you
ask, what is psi square,
it scales with 2l.
And at least for
large n, the n-scaling
is, again, 1 over n cubed.
OK, that's what I wanted
to present you today.
Any questions?
OK, so we meet again
on Wednesday next week.